I don't know the point of what I'm doing
is if I can't protect the people that
are closest to me here please so the
only person who is responsible for what
happened to felicity
is damian darhk--
you were holding a man prisoner as some
personal vendetta
we're spirited or do you have any idea
how many people damian darhk-- and i
have killed over the past six months
it's might be a vendetta but it's not
personal do you remember what I promised
you
a new beginning and you will have it
once we've brought this world to its end
someone else is throwing their hat in
the ring you to endorse me good luck
right I know you want payback for what
dark did for this but the lose we made
her fall in love with you in the first
place
John
think the reason they're winning because
I haven't wanted to go far enough
I've been holding off telling you this
for years Oliver you're very handsome
not especially bright
hey youtubers is Charlie there's a new
arrow trailer for the second half of the
season there's footage from a bunch of
different episodes so this is going to
be a breakdown so much DC stuff
happening tonight this week so the
biggest surprise from the trailer
Roy is back katana is back the actress
who plays shado is back it might be her
twin in season 3 they revealed in
Oliver's flashbacks the shadow had a
twin that Oliver didn't know about so
either this is her twin or this is in a
super flashback but I don't think we've
seen actual shado off of the island in
any of the flashbacks before katana
showing up also confirms that just
because characters are going to be in
the big Suicide Squad franchise in the
movies they can still be on the TV show
so they could still probably do Suicide
Squad stories but I'm not expecting a
whole lot of that because they've done
that in the past and they they try not
to recycle too many things season to
season I don't know about you guys but I
was pretty disappointed with the katana
arc in season 3 so hopefully season 4
will be able to have a little bit more
fun with her the the basic arc of the
trailer is Oliver questioning whether or
not his methods of trying to do things
aboveboard or effective against damian
darhk-- because all the people he loves
keep getting hurt like you see Willa
this is from a previous episode but then
as he's talking to canary kind of throws
forward you see her almost dying you see
Lyla almost getting shot and on the flip
side of things we learned that the woman
the damian darhk-- is talking to about
you know bringing this new world talking
about a new beginning the same woman
from the end of episode 9 who it looks
like might be his wife they might have a
child together she's going to be running
against all of our campaigning against
Oliver for mayor really no idea where
that arc is going I think they're just
using them to build out the damian
darhk-- character make him seem like a
more complete person like he has his own
family that he's trying to protect even
if he is going about it in a very evil
way expect the same kind of thing on the
flash where they build out the zoom
character slowly episode 2 episode where
you learn why it is he needs Barry's
speed so much like why he needs to be
the fastest but let's talk about Roy and
God felicity here so the Roy episode is
going to be the calculator episode
they're bringing the calculator on the
show he's going to be Felicity's father
so I'm assuming this goth Felicity
flashback is a callback to the season 3
episode where they did a flashback to
her in college where she was super goth
doubt the ROI calculator episode is
going to be really big in general but I
think it's also going to be a big
felicity art I think Felicity is going
to be out of commission for
while like she'll be in a wheelchair
unable to walk for a while but she's not
going to be the Oracle character so
she's not going to be paralyzed forever
so what if she starts getting out of the
chair in that episode with her father
like it becomes this big victory for her
like she defeats the calculator and gets
out of the chair defeating my father in
defeating my disability at the same time
but even if she doesn't get out of the
chair I think you guys are going to dig
where they're taking the Felicity
character in the back half I think a lot
of people complain because it feels like
she doesn't have a meaningful arc they
insert her to do quit punch up because
Oliver and some of the other characters
are so serious so she's kind of like the
comedy in the group this though getting
out of the wheelchair defeating her
disability and dealing with her father
coming back into the picture in a big
way that's real character development so
I'm actually really excited about
felicity in the back half Merlyn has
that sick burn Oliver you look really
awesome but you were just the dumbest
thing on the planet John Barrowman is
writing that Malcolm Merlyn comic I
think it's digital-only
and it's set between seasons three and
four like you learn what Merlyn did in
his early days as Rachele Ghul it adds a
lot of nice context to the character
during season one like when they first
introduced the Malcolm Merlyn character
they said the pitch was imagine if Bruce
Wayne went to the League of Assassins
and when he had that test where Rachel
Ghul was like here is a thief you need
to kill him
they say Malcolm Merlyn presented with
that situation is the Bruce Wayne that
executed that man like what if Bruce
Wayne was super dark that is who Malcolm
Merlyn is and that's kind of the way he
reads in this Malcolm erlich comic book
and the other big thing in the trailer
here is anarchy there's a whole bunch of
anarchy all up and down the trailer I
think he's showing up relatively early
in the back half of the season he might
even show up in this week's episode but
you kind of get the idea that Oliver's
actions the actions of team arrow pushed
him over the edge just as much as damian
darhk-- pushed him over the edge part
part of the anarchy pitch was is that
you have this kid who runs into damian
darhk-- and team arrow and both share
equal responsibilities both groups share
equal responsibility for turning him
into the anarchy character so oliver
trying to torture him here probably not
going to end well let me know what you
guys think of the trailer like what does
it make you really excited for I know
everyone's really hyped to see Roy back
I think that that's going to be episode
14 but there's also a new zoom clip for
the flash episode tonight so I'm going
to play it right here
I know I'm moving pretty fast but stop
me if you've heard this one before boy
needs girl happens every day except this
boy was struck by lightning and became
the fastest man alive
so nothing is ever that simple ho oh my
Oh careful oh sorry it's all good it's
all good
those weren't for me anyway right they
were I didn't realize roses were so
flammable oh my god
well it's the thought that counts and
you know in popper fire safety
management bet that counts best I have
spent most of my life feeling very
unlucky Dan now feels like I've been
struck by lightning twice
flash everything you have will be mine
so a couple things about this one I
think it's a nightmare it might not
actually be happening
but think about what zoom says
everything you have will be mine doesn't
that sound like something that evil
Barry from earth to evil Wally or evil
Eddie would say even if zoom is an evil
earth to Henry Allen I don't think he
would try to kill Barry's girlfriend he
wouldn't want to take his life that
sounds like something a younger
character would say but something about
this just makes me feel like it's a
nightmare that Barry's having and it's
not actually happening but I believe
it's the first couple of minutes from
tonight's episode so we won't have to
wait that long to find out what's going
on in [ __ ] that there is a new round of
the reverse flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
I'll do the first giveaway when I post
my Suicide Squad video later tonight so
there's a Suicide Squad trailer coming
that'll probably be my first video out
if there's Wonder Woman footage I'll do
a video for that next then I'll do my
flash episode so there ends up being a
whole bunch of new footage for a bunch
of different things you might not see my
flash video till early Wednesday morning
just in case I'll post it as fast as
possible and you can follow me on
Twitter and Facebook for updates on when
videos are posting it should all post
pretty quickly why guys wait for
everything to post you can click here
for all my Batman V Superman Suicide
Squad videos and you can click here for
the flash trailer from last night thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight